now for our reaction we got a rock star
panel tonight we got rights free this
former White House chief of staff and
former RNC chair Byron York Washington
Examiner chief political correspondent
Fox News contributor and Dennis Kucinich
former Democratic congressman and 2008
presidential candidate
Harmeet Dillon is with a civil rights
attorney Trump 2020 advisory board
member Reince let's start with you what
a president Trump and his allies
thinking tonight watching what happened
in this second Democrat debate well as I
was watching it I thought there were two
winners tonight
number one president Trump very clearly
because number one the Democrats are
debating throwing off 200 million people
off their private insurance they're
trashing Barack Obama they're talking
about Medicare for all another 32
trillion and that second winners Joe
Biden because one thing I learned in
2016 is that when it was all Trump all
the time no matter good bad in the
middle Trump always won in that battle
tonight was all about Joe Biden
constantly attacking him nine on one it
was all about Biden he's plus 20 going
in at a debate if anything he was helped
by the debate and I think ultimately it
was a good night for him and a great
night for the president
biron what stood out when I watch this
thing was my goodness if Barack Obama
showed up on stage he would be one of
the more conservative people on that
stage and they'd have to attack him
standing right there this was amazing to
see the party of doom and gloom pretty
much everyone was doom and gloom except
Biden who but I think was saying elect
me and we're gonna do Obama 3.0 he does
he's I mean look he has always been the
candidate of restoration I mean there
are other candidates of transformation
he's the candidate of restoration but
you know watching this I think if you
are a Democrat and you truly think the
house is on fire that we're in a big
emergency because of Donald Trump this
debate started out with 40 minutes of
arcane discussion of health care in
which they did discuss whether or not to
take away people's private insurance
came to no particular conclusion and
nobody gave that sense of emergency that
the Democratic base is feeling they
weren't seeing it
their candidates dennis kucinich you've
argued a lot of these issues in the past
that you have to take on the big dogs in
your party in order to be a
transformational candidate but tonight
it was it was an odd thing to watch
because again Barack Obama was two-term
president extremely popular global
superstar but pretty much all of them
were hitting Obama without necessarily
saying it Obamacare trade deals they did
it last night too
and then Biden's there saying whoa wait
a second that was a party of hope and
change well there's a couple things here
first of all I think we we have to
acknowledge that some of the
deficiencies of the Obama administration
created the opening for Donald Trump now
as far as health care there is a real
divide among Democrats on health care
and there has been for decades in 2000 I
was went to the Democratic platform
committee to present Medicare for all
and it was shot down by the gore
campaign this is and and the support for
Medicare for all is growing you wouldn't
know it by tonight's debate but you
would certainly know it from yesterday's
with Bernie Sanders yeah we had Delaney
though I think I think John Delaney the
only one with business experience other
than Andrew yang said look I ran two
health care companies Medicare pays for
80% of what doctors actually need to
cover their costs Medicare for all will
crater what is already going to crater
which is Medicare but the problem here
is we got Biden and Camilla Harris I
mean I want you to come on up get in on
this they're mixing it up at the very
beginning of this debate over this
medicare-for-all conversation it's hard
to follow for most people who don't know
the issues this is how it went down Vice
President Biden's campaign calls your
plan quote a habit every which way
approach and says it's just part of a
confusing pattern of equivocating about
your health care stance what do you say
to that well they're probably confused
because they've not read it anytime
someone tells you to get something good
in ten years you should wonder why it
takes ten years it will require
middle-class taxes to go up not down the
cost of doing nothing is far too
expensive
did Joe Biden win that exchange Harmeet
well I think he pointed out that Kamala
Harris is all over the place he could
have done a better job he could have
pointed out that actually yesterday
Bernie said that his plan which Kamala
Harris has previously endorsed and I
think even co-sponsored eliminates
private health care altogether he just
came out and said it and owned it Kamala
Harris's problem as I wrote in a Wall
Street Journal op-ed a little while ago
is that she's flip-flopped on every
single major issue she wants to have it
all of the different ways and after that
like 20-30 minutes of discussion and her
having five times the airtime any of the
other candidates she still wouldn't say
how much it's gonna cost and what it
really accomplishes so I do think that
Biden did a better job there in that
exchange than Kamala Harris I would I
would have to agree and that Senator
Harris has been all over the map it her
proposal on so-called Medicare for all
really isn't it looks like a duck but it
quacks like an insurance company okay
Brian
the most devastating blow to Harris
again who was built up much like bado
ork was built up and Budaj edge was
built up then it was Harris and their
candidate build him up but she's been
built up for for weeks and weeks and
weeks so this was another moment for her
to shine this was the most devastating
blow to her watch
she put over 1,500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana
[Applause]
have freed an innocent man from death
row until the courts forced her to do so
she kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of California there is no
excuse for that and the people who
suffered under your reign as prosecutor
oh you owe them an apology and she
basically answered no that's not true
but she never really told us why that
wasn't true and I don't know who's gonna
fact-check Carla Harris that might work
in general for Kamala Harris she's tough
on crime but in this primary in this
temperature does that work Minh twerk
you can't have it both ways but also you
know these candidates that are not
Kamala Harris and not Joe Biden they're
preparing pre preparing for these
attacks Tulsi Gabbar went in there ready
to attack Kamala Harris because she's in
the second position these other
candidates are on the attack
here here's the one thing that reminds
me of 2016 the difference between 2016
and now the one thing the Democrats are
getting right the rest of the field is
they're all attacking Biden they're all
trying to take him down I don't think
it's going to work right now but they're
all attacking remember in 2016 the the
Republican Kenneth did not attack Donald
Trump they were afraid and only until
the end but they were afraid to tack
Donald Trump they only attacked each
other they knocked each other out of the
game and Trump was standing there and
they were afraid to go after him they're
not afraid to go after Joe Biden they
know that if they don't knock him down a
couple notches within the next two
months
I think it's be very difficult I also
think the DNC is on the brink of losing
complete control over this primary once
explain this to us it's an important
point everybody has to listen to what
Ryan's is saying right
once these candidates start to fade off
once the field starts to narrow it takes
nothing if CNN wants to do a debate
every single night with seven of these
candidates they can get three times the
viewership so if you're at 1% in Iowa
say we're all at 1% in Iowa Laura's at
30% now why would we not why would we
not have a debate every night on CNN the
three of us to try to catch up with you
and the reason the reason why the DNC
needs to get control is that these 19 18
15 candidates are going to go on their
own they're going to
rogue and this is about to break loose
and I think you're seeing this started
siren interesting I like the intrigue
the palace intrigue at the DNC DCC is
having trouble to well this is the last
time you're gonna see most of these
candidates on stage in a debate the
rules change the next time you have to
have to qualify for the debate at least
two percent in the polls either
nationally or in a number of state polls
right now six or seven members of Ko
falls out absolutely let's get some
predictions default a bottom dozen
follow who on the bottom now who right
now do you think we're gonna make it
wants to stay in our the top for Bernie
Biden Harris Warren and Booker maybe and
Buddha judge and about that's about it
the rest of them are going away because
they will not they could still pop up on
Santa right because CNN what is to stop
ten of these candidates say they get
knocked out what's to stop those ten
from doing a debate unseen it did you
can see also right but the DNC about
they have not tied the debate calendar
to the nomination process they have not
tie I get what you're saying to the
rules of the nomination so it is a
free-for-all there is nothing preventing
candidates from doing their own thing
Dennis Kucinich you and I talked about
this before this this show get began I
keep thinking of the guys who were the
and it could be guys or gals but who was
just master campaigners Barack Obama
Bill Clinton Donald Trump george w bush
they were I mean not just because they
won but they were phenomenal just retail
politician who on that stage tonight
other than Biden has that kind of common
touch he can be a little
self-deprecating yeah he can slur his
words every now and that but you know I
don't think anyone cares about that who
comes close to being a retail politician
with some pizzazz I didn't see it and I
I mean I was trying to just look at it
as an analyst I did not see that kind of
Obama Trump go get it I didn't see it
well it's still early
Mary Ann willing
with us it's still early in the in the
campaign and I think that you can't get
elected to some of the office these
people hold without having some Scot
retail but I also think that I would be
very careful to write anybody off right
now well it's true that presidents in a
debate can determine if somebody's going
to be visible to the American people
there's still a lot of movement I think
and tonight one of the I think you
picked it up Tulsi Gabbard for example
that exchange that Javits Center look at
her it shows her vulnerability Kamala
Harris is vulnerability she can't answer
Tulsi Gabbard she's I liked all together
but if you can't answer her are you
think you're gonna go Toto Trump
Saturday a prosecutor is good on offense
yeah and she's good on offense but
senator Harris didn't do well on defense
now Harmeet democrats have a new phrase
for we can't answer or don't want to
answer this question watch republican
talking points in order to talk with
each other about how to best provide
that out there Jake your question is a
Republican talking point we cannot keep
with the Republican talking points on
this you got to stop open borders is a
right wing talking point I mean that's a
cute trick car mate isn't it but I may
be lame when you're here and again and
again and and what what they don't like
is the Republican reality outside that
room the reality that Donald Trump has
been the best president ever for
criminal justice reform which is
something they purport to care about for
African American jobs for education for
a rising tide for all Americans and for
forge for you know for everything in our
economy and so they don't like those
facts they are painting and conjuring
this picture of this dystopian America
where the seas are rising and we are
shivering and you know Huddle's and
cages on the streets and none of that is
really true so I think it's not working
it's very fake I mean you know Laura I
think you're pointing to this most of
these candidates are totally fake I you
know Kirsten Gillibrand thanks for
playing but you know
ohayo and exploits plain whiteness to
white women and what is that it's crazy
so you know I think you're right Biden
is the only one who was authentic but
he's got his own problems I actually
think he improved Visa be the last
debate when Paris is gonna go down in
the polls after her perm is a nightmare
for Harris tonight this is a nightmare
we haven't even gotten to the trade
stuff what happened on immigration
Castro just completely embarrassed
himself on immigration but rights to
that point about how now Biden positions
himself going to this next debate
because I think he rose above the
cacophony of all this I mean he was he
was up there defending Obamacare all the
rest of the people are like trashing
Obama sits in a great place to be either
with the American people well it's
fairly possibly better than green New
Deal and Medicare for all but here's the
issue and Harmeet hit on it which is all
the the prominent Democrats have is all
these positions green new deal Medicare
for all reparations on early end job
security mandatory paid vacation is how
does that play out in Pittsburgh
Milwaukee Columbus Cleveland what do
those people think of those positions
and it doesn't work we're just talking
about you know I think Cory Booker said
something about the Paris climate Accord
being you know the child's play and I
thought that nobody never they're giving
away and I think President Trump said it
well when he announced it on the in the
Rose Garden when he said we're about
Pittsburgh not Paris Trump wins that
argument every single day so they can
have their debate as Byron opened up
they can have this this this esoteric
debate but in the end it's the positions
of this president that is going to help
him win in the Midwest and these
positions are going to kill the Democrat
Party a Byron it's a lot of money we're
talking about we're talking about
trillions upon trillions of dollars
they're also saying welcome everyone
into the coat anyone who wants to come
in basically when you boil it all down
anyone can come in for any reason except
maybe if you're a murderer then we don't
really want you here but other than that
if you show up you're gonna stay so
we're gonna we're gonna all die in 12
years climate change rising seas Flint
Michigan's segregation in the seventy
read relitigated bussing this just
seemed a total disconnect from what you
dennis kucinich I've talked about your
whole life Reince Priebus is from the
Midwest the Rust Belt the Midwest is
still where this election is going to be
won or lost in my view last night was a
more progressive crowd and on
immigration remember in the the previous
debate and they all basically raised
their hands and said they were in favor
of decriminalizing illegal crossings of
the border last night was just
completely progressive tonight you did
have somebody who - Joe Biden say that
you know it's illegal to cross the
border illegally and but but he is not
in the majority here and and this is all
of this is going to be on the record so
they've basically all come out and said
we are in favor of effective open
borders they can try to change that when
the general election comes around but
we've already seen it now later on we're
gonna get to how de Blasio three times
tried to take out Joe Biden on the issue
of immigration he went three times bite
at the Apple on deportations which again
Dennis I know you're more progressive
than some of these mid you know Midwest
more centrist Democrats but you still
have to put together that electoral map
how do you put the electoral map
together when it's basically Republican
time but not open borders endless
spending guaranteed income reparations
green New Deal Medicare for all well I
would present it in a different package
I would say Medicare for all mandatory
the Democrats ought to stand for that
and I think they can win on that I also
think you went on on jobs and wages 99%
of America has seen a wage increase the
Wall Street Journal piece today was
devastating on that 99 percent of the
top that 99 percent of Americans have
seen their wages basically go up big
screaming headline in the journal today
well the question is by what degree and
and that's something matter than Obama
and look I'm not arguing about the Obama
administration here versus the Trump
administration I'm speaking in a
relative sense about whether or not
there's there's hope for particularly
working-class people in Ohio who is it
now who have been shut out of
a lot of the gains in the economy was
gonna it does anyone on that stage
really think Harmeet that they're gonna
do a better job at creating jobs and
Donald Trump or they're gonna do a
better job at a health care reform than
job I mean then Barack Obama I don't I
don't see it I think to make with this
economy
there's rebuild the infrastructure
that's something to do the Democrats
don't want to do the inference well
because you can't work with someone who
they say is there is a mistake I mean
they're arguing against you John Castro
was arguing that this is not a good
economy tonight that's really that's
right I mean they have nothing to
complain about if they we're going to
talk about the facts here they have to
you know demonize the president which is
you know getting very tired it isn't
talking about solutions for Americans
and and they have a completely altered
view of reality on the one hand
everybody from other countries can come
into the country and stay here on the
other hand the taxpayers are gonna pay
for with what money and so I think that
they really failed at at that and when
it comes to Donald Trump and getting up
against any of these I can't wait to see
that and we're not going to see it as
many of the other guests have pointed
out tonight most of these people are you
know gonna take their consolation prize
and go for the most part but I don't see
how any of them are going to do better
than Trump at a lot of the issues they
talked about at immigration I mean you
know Biden who was a leading Canada
there he took some hits for the fact
that his administration had deported
yeah we want to get into them because I
don't I want to get I don't want to get
to what I just mentioned when hitting
guide and other 20/20 damn is also piled
on the President Obama's legacy watch
when the issue came up with all those
deportations you were Vice printed
States I didn't hear whether you tried
to stop them or not using your power
your influence in the White House
President came along and he's the guy
that came up with the idea the first
time ever dealing with the dreamers
compare him to Donald Trump I think is
absolutely bizarre I don't hear an
answer from the vice president he moved
to fundamentally changed the system
that's what he did mr. vice president
you can't have it both ways you invoke
President Obama more than anybody in
this campaign you can't do it when it's
convenient
and then dodge it when it's not writes
who won the better of that one it is
true that the President Obama had a lot
of deportations so now the conclusion is
Obama was too too conservative for this
Democrat Party I think it's a tough sell
in a Democrat Party right now and that's
why Biden's 20 points up I mean I think
the party has to be very careful here I
think that the party and me and others
get it's easy for us to dismiss this
entire field as completely whacko but
the one guy that's not necessarily in
that category is +20 over the rest so I
think it's important for the party to
focus in on Joe Biden talk about the
fact that he's for the green new deal he
came out in favor of it ninety-three
trillion I think it's important that
that we don't lose sight of that and I I
think that Barack Obama's far too
popular still within the Democrat base
is much different than Bush in oh wait
and 2010 when you had Cruz and Mike Lee
and everyone you know just running from
different 55% of Democrats today want to
continue Obama's legacy so they're up
their trash in Obama's deal I do not
think that Biden completely laid to rest
concerns about his age about his
sharpness there was enough halting this
in his performance enough conclusion of
difficulties in in formulating ideas
that I don't think this is going away an
age is going to be a problem from now on
for him I would have to agree with Byron
to the extent that the vice president
seemed to interrupt himself a few times
and that he broke the flow of his own
presentation which didn't help him I
also think that Cory Booker did a pretty
good job in putting the Vice President
to the test I mean why is Cory Booker
not really catching on I mean he's well
you know he's fairly Arty's articulate
ease but we were arguing Newark police
policy at one point we're arguing NYPD
then we were arguing Newark then we were
arguing it seemed like that we're not
saying it's not important but as for a
Democrat Prime
it seemed very you know really really
granular I don't think again I think
most of it went over people's heads well
even if you don't get it down into the
granular aspects of it I do think Biden
laid a couple of good blows on him with
respect to how he had lied and had the
ACLU it accused Booker of etcetera but I
think the point is he comes across even
like if you turned off the volume and
just lists left look at the body
language he comes across as very kind of
shrill hyper you know kind of you know
in your face you know we saw that in the
Kavanagh hearings we've seen that in
virtually all of his performances are
all it up at 11 you know and this is
spinal tap they're like just one note
and it's just too much and people don't
want that they want they want it I think
they want a bite and who's functioning I
think that's the problem is that you
know Biden the halting and like the you
know the the kind of mini stroke type
situation I think that that was very
discomforting to watch it was very awful
to watch all right Jaime panel thank you
for joining us
Reince Byron and Dennis please stand by